there's an interesting discussion that's
emerged following what happened in
Nashville where they're saying you know
a bunch of conservatives were like maybe
we shouldn't allow trans people to have
guns or something like that and I'm just
like not interested in that not not
interested in that conversation if
someone poses a clear and present danger
or like I mean like they're literally on
on the path choosing a weapon right you
can stop them but short of I guess due
process maybe they committed a felony
and a court has determined through
through somehow yeah a legal Pro like
due process yeah your rights cannot be
infringed upon well you bring up a good
point everyone wants to talk about the
gun thing well the government has guns I
mean criminals have guns everyone
already has guns the guns shouldn't even
be the best you said the same thing
twice what was that oh yeah the
criminals in the government yeah exactly
but they all have guns so like that
shouldn't be the discussion if trans
people have guns fine if if you know the
LGBT community wants to have guns that's
fine everyone's everyone can have guns
let's talk about other things instead
but got gun owners and I'm just going to
say that are some of the biggest wusses
out there like they really are and 2020
we saw this because For the Longest Time
Governors were like we have guns for the
government and then 2020 happened we had
the antifa stuff and made the peaceful
Times Obviously and then they went oh
there's other people with guns who
aren't our friends we need to do
something about that or have the
government step in it's like no no no no
no don't don't ask for the government to
step in you're having them do what we
don't want them to do to us what you do
is you train exactly that's what you do
just be better than everyone because
most people aren't going out there and
training I mean I'm I I'm a guy that's
very Pro get out there and train go out
there and like learn how to shoot your
guns I mean Lucas knows how to shoot
guns when did you guys get interested in
guns like is this something you grew up
with is there something that happened I
played Call of Duty and that was enough
for me I actually video games gun
pipeline video games are the Gateway the
Gateway they they they create more gun
owners in the NRA ever hopes to yeah
is like oh they're they're gone yeah
they're gone I'm not a big fan but yeah
video games absolutely Call of Duty
franchise which I'm very thankful I got
to work on the good one that came guys
years ago guys guys the NRA is very
important it's a very important
organization we need to make sure that
the NRA you gotta donate a lot of money
we need to make sure that the NRA is out
there so that way they've got something
to attack didn't the NRA support the NFA
oh they've supported they've so the NRA
has done some good things like the
sunset clause for the weapons assault
ban and all that but for the most part
they are extremely funny the worst thing
about the NRA that people won't talk
about are is their training programs
which are like they have a they have a
like a rule you are not allowed to call
a gun a weapon that's all right that's
too dangerous and real quick describe
explain fuddy to people who don't know
so funny or like people who go uh 1911
is better than any pistol out there won
two world wars
is better than an air 15. it's still
very esoteric esoteric so I don't want
that stuff on my rifle it's it's a
reference to Elmer Fudd yep yeah it's
old old times more or less he's not
getting times these people who are like
look I'm I'm a gun owner and I think we
should have gun control and it's like I
don't generally that we don't need 30
rounds for hunting so let's ban 30 round
high capacity magazines to go to 10 do
you see deer running around Kevlar what
do you need that for exactly that's
exactly it but yeah the NRA the the
worst thing is not their political stuff
it's the firearms training it's the
culture that they're perpetuating to
even hunter's education don't store
ammunition with a gun the gun's pretty
useless without the ammunition like you
actually want to keep them together
because weapons are for people not just
for Bambi but these these and they train
them young that way these people have
never loaded a weapon no and so I I can
tell you this right
um I got a 30 30 uh Winchester repeater
it's amazing and it's it's real
difficult to load the 33rd yes they get
stuck the the the the plunger gets stuck
and all that stuff and then when it
comes to loading even like you know a
Glock with nine millimeter they have
speed loaders for a reason if you if
you're trained in your practice you can
load it fairly quickly but I just think
anybody who has a gun understands that
if someone if you hear you're a glass
shatter and then someone yell all right
boys let's go you're gonna be like oh
and then you're gonna open the box and
you're gonna be like just give me a
second let me push these in and load
this no it has to like when when you're
when you are being prepared for
self-defense you you need to have your
weapon prepared and safely secured in a
way yeah you know that you can access it
and that uh it's responsible but what's
the point someone told me this
when um I was asking like around the
first time I was getting a weapon what's
proper like storage and safety protocol
and I'm going to keep it relatively
vague for the show but they just
basically said what's the point of
having a weapon if you can't readily
exit to defend yourself from an intruder
so just consider that yep and then have
a serious conversation with yourself
what is a gun for yeah they are for Homo
sapiens they were designed ever since
gunpowder was you know developed and
then it was used for fire fireworks to
disrupt Cavalry Charges after that it
was always weaponized for human beings
it wasn't just made for hunting like
that is what they're for and the problem
is gun owners well it's a weapon every
time I say that they go they go oh Lucas
you can't say that because then the
left's gonna use that to ban stuff I'm
like no the reason we're in all this
mess and gun regulations are happening
is we've always been on the defense and
culturally we're losing because of it we
won't just say the facts and what's
going on I I think it's fair to be more
general what weapons are for destructive
ends yep and that doesn't mean it's
always bad destructive things can be
good things right if if you're defending
someone a machete for instance you're
using it to go in clear brush to to
carve a path through the woods to help
people more freely move about but it's
also can be the weapon yeah and uh
famously Alfred Nobel made dynamite TNT
I think I don't know the same thing but
TNT I guess because he wanted to help
people mine and then they called him The
Merchant of death and he was and they
you know the story like they
accidentally published his obituary and
then he was like is that what they think
of me he's like holy crap oh that must
be brutal that he read his obituary
before he passed yeah and then you and
then he made the piece the Nobel prizes
he was like I better be known for
something much better than that I didn't
know that yeah but it was weapon
obituaries and Records let's let's go
back to that first the first question
with all of us we're talking about uh
mental illness uh weapon ownership and
stuff like that and for the longest time
we were talking about red flag laws and
everybody on the right and all the
two-way people were like absolutely not
you cannot red flag people and then the
Nashville shooting happened and all of a
sudden conservatives were like we should
not let these people have guns and I'm
just sitting here like yo wrong yeah
well so the mental the mental um
that that whole thing's interesting
because the issue that I have with that
whole conversation is by what standard
and who gets to Define if someone is
mentally unwell because if I go to the
right you know uh you know doctor
clinician or whatever and I say I really
like guns for these reasons this is what
I actually think about the government
this is what I think about balkanization
of our country next one in XYZ they
could say you're a little unwell for
thinking these things you want to
homeschool your kids you're married
you're not running around doing all this
other stuff you're on well you can't own
guns right that's I'm not saying that
would happen today but in 10 years I
mean who gets to standardize who is
mentally well and so that's a pretty
slippery slope this is why when a couple
years ago we were talking about uh
felons and firearms and I said as soon
as you get out of jail you get your
right to keeping bear arms yep I agree
and what people responded with was
several people conservatives were like
no because you went through a process
you you got your due process and through
due process your rights were deprived
that is constitutional meaning you have
a right to life liberty in the pursuit
of happiness but if you break the law we
can deprive you of those rights through
due process meaning you went to a judge
there was a hearing you were found
guilty the same thing is true of your
guns and my response that is then just
like so what is a life sentence then
yeah it's either you die or I guess
you're in jail your whole life yeah
that's yeah you don't get yourself
and so my my issue still is now due
process isn't necessarily an app a a
perfect standard right because we are we
are at the point of polarization in this
country where like you said you will say
something like I think everybody should
have guns I'm like well you're clearly
insane things that have one I think
machine guns should be legal okay I also
wonder how the mental health screenings
work because we have the shooter in
Louisville whose parents are like no he
was having some sort of Crisis we were
aware of it like but he was able to get
a gun theoretically like wouldn't this
have triggered so I feel like some
people can I just don't understand in
the Practical applications of some of
these yeah and the problem is p the
government and people want to play
Minority Report they want to stop the
crime before it happens you can't do
that it doesn't actually work oh but
it's coming Theo yeah I know the AI chat
gp7 whatever is gonna probably do it but
it's not practical and it's not going to
work and it's only going to cause and
we've seen this up north where red flag
loss have gotten innocent people killed
where they show up to the doorstep the
guy comes out there's an altercation
he's like why are you guys here I
haven't done Community crimes yet ends
up getting shot there's been at least
two of those uh that have happened
um it's going to do more harm than good
and besides that according to all these
shootings have happened at least in the
last like five years uh supposedly the
FBI already knew about the person yeah
they're constantly already watching them
so it's like well it obviously doesn't
work already I mean you guys have been
trying to do this kind of the FBI tries
to prevent crimes right they're just
aware of stuff is going on but they're
like maybe we'll help you assist do that
crime yeah that's yeah it's a slippery
slope and it's not something that I
think I think conservatives and people
in generally to get away from and just
go when a crime happens we have people
there who can shoot back and that's how
we resolve it because we call the cops
to resolve it while attack after while
it's happening so why not address it
sooner when the incident actually occurs
and if we saw that happen more often a
lot of these shootings would go down if
people realize like hey if we posted
photos of the corpse of the shooter
afterwards kind of what happened in
Tennessee a lot less of this shooter
culture would be happening I mean I
don't know I guess my concern is there
are a lot of people with no purpose
anymore and no community and no path
towards notability right and and maybe
notability is the wrong word but but
people want recognition value feeling
value and so they decide one way they'll
make people remember their names
is being evil yeah because uh if they
can't be a famous superhero they'll just
be the villain it's the easiest path
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
on uncensored members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time